Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P The topic of tipping
continues to titillate the audience. The egg man
calling in with another tipping related question.
Speaker 4: Hey, Dave, I have a question about
tipping when you're traveling in Europe. Okay.
Speaker 3: So, you know, I lived
in Italy for almost a year.
Speaker 4: Many years ago, I
married a foreigner. Right.
We went out to eat often and they don't tip there,
obviously. Right. So I have a meal and I wouldn't
leave a tip. Sometimes I would get a dirty.
Speaker 3: Look from the waitstaff.
Speaker 4: For leaving them a 20% tip on top
of the meal. I felt weird about tipping, right?
Speaker 1: And so I guess in some
countries when you leave a tip,
it's seen as you think the restaurant must be
struggling, so you leave them extra money. That's
why in some places it's seen as offensive to tip.
Speaker 3: And then when I wouldn't.
Speaker 4: Tip because you just don't
tip. I'm paying a lot for this meal.
I felt like then I would get a dirty look
like, Dude, we know you're American. You
can't come here and not tip. Yeah, Americans have
to tip you. Only Italians don't have to tip here.
So, Dave, have you ever.
Speaker 3: Noticed any of
those things shallow over?
Speaker 1: Yes. Shalom. I
have noticed those things there. Sometimes
there's a bit of a double standard on tipping
my again, I'm against tipping. I just, like, price
everything in and I'll decide if it's worth it,
you know, and then it ignores it avoids
all of these travel problems and cultural,
you know, inconsistencies on tipping. That
being said, I will play the game. I will look
up what is expected in each country and in
some countries. It's like now you just round
up to the next dollar, okay? In some countries
it's like 5 to 10% max for good service but not
expect it. And I just try to do what's expected.
I agree. It's all horrifying. Now I will say
my experience is in Italy where everybody wants
a tip. There was once a I stayed at a hotel
in the Amalfi on the Amalfi Coast, and I think
there were six different opportunities for tips.
As soon as I pulled up in my rental car, someone
came out and wanted the keys in order to park the
car. So that was tip opportunity, number one. Tip
opportunity number two was the person who insisted
on bringing my luggage into the hotel. Tip number
three was the person who insisted on bringing the
luggage from the lobby up to my room. Tip number
four was the person who came up to the room and
insisted on giving me a full tour, including like
how light switches and toilets work. It's like,
I'm not Trump, I know how toilets work. I'm
not going around thinking I have to flush them
10 to 15 times. And fifth opportunity for
tipping was when you want the rental car.
They put it in a lot where you could easily just
walk into the lot and get it, but it they get
it for you. So it creates a fifth opportunity for
leaving a tip. So it was tip crazy in in in Italy.
You should have seen what was going on. All right.
Great bonus show for you today. Just trust me.
I won't even tease what's on today's bonus show.
It's a good one. Sign up at joint parkland dot com